hello everyone and welcome back to the
capablanca saga we are continuing the
1919 match between Capablanca and the
Borislav Kostich it's a Game five and
cava Blanca is leading four to zero so
something no one expected and no one
would even imagine as that once again I
will repeat every game they played prior
to this match ended in a draw so without
further ado let's just check out Game
five as this is the shortest of the
games and well it just shows it what
what kind of condition Kostich was in at
this point in the match it's also
interesting Bobby Fischer also analyzed
this game for Serbian television
alongside Dmitri Bill its [ __ ] this
video is available on YouTube I will put
a link to it in the description below it
will be the first thing you will see so
if you want you can also check out the
footage isn't great but you know it's
Bobby Fischer why not to check it out so
the first link in the description below
now let's check out this game capablanca
has the white pieces and he opens with E
4 and here border goes for East 6 the
French defense with d4 d5 and Knight to
c3 with Knight to f6 the main line
Bishop to g5 and now D captures on e4
the burn variation with Knight captures
and are threatening to mess up black's
pawn structure here Knight B to d7 and
here Knight to f3 ah kappa blanka
continues development development we
have Bishop to e7 and here
the knight is no longer pin so black is
threatening to capture on e4 Capablanca
trades once with Knight captures on e4
and here Knight captures sorry on f6 and
here Knight captures on f6 if you check
out the link that I mentioned Bobby
Fischer says that he played this
position against Tigran Petrosian in
1962 our petrosyan went Bishop captures
on f6 and Knight captures on f6 the move
Kostich place fischer mentions that it's
not all that great as it well it
prevents black from further trading down
which of course favors white and white
will have more attacking chances here
Cobra Blanca continues Bishop to d3 you
want your Bishop on this nice diagonal
and now b6 Costas prepares to fianchetto
the light square bishop of course we
have the b7 diagonal with castles by
Capablanca and now Bishop to b7 and here
just Queen 2e to the
helping the queen connecting rooks with
castles by Kostich and now rook a to d1
aligning the rook nicely with the Queen
also you have to develop it and here h6
trying to either force a couple Annika
to capture or to move away the bishop
but as Fischer says that this is a weak
move but Fischer says about every move
that he doesn't agree with it's a weak
move and now forces the bishop to
retreat of course capablanca isn't
interested in capturing the shop to f4
and now comes Queen to d5 another move
that Fischer characterizes as a week of
course you have to be careful what you
do with the knight as Queen captures and
g2 will be the threat of checkmate but
here Kostich is basically saying okay
you capture my opponent c7 I'm gonna
capture a pawn on a - but capablanca
just pushes the Queen away we have c4
and now it's interesting what do you do
with the Queen if you go to h5 or to a5
white always has something in store
if you click Queen h5 just Bishop
captures on c7 and it's a clean pawn if
Bishop captures on f3 white can't even
play G captures on f3 and it's not a
problem because white can always bring
the bishop back you will have no problem
defending this position you will just
enjoy your extra pawn on the other hand
if you go Queen to a5 you just capture
the point and it's pretty much the same
Fischer mentions that you can go d5 as
there is the existence of this pin the
bishop on e7 is unguarded but here it
seems the the engine disagrees
you can go rook 88 but of course that's
you know besides the point
because here after captures Bishop to c5
and captures again black would have
compensation for the pawn due to such
nice development but all in all white
white should still be better but okay
after c4 with Queen back to d8 hostage
now loses two moves her queen to d5 back
to d8 and here kappa blanka just plays
Knight to e5 improving the position of
his knight that's now a beautiful piece
of course you cannot capture the pawn
here if you capture it then the shop h7
check wins the Queen so tonight the d7
of
a trade here and here Capablanca just
played Bishop to be one and believe it
or not it was in this position unmoved
15 that caustic resigned in the game and
with this resignation he basically for a
forfeited the match as now Capablanca is
a five five to zero in the lead and of
course it was supposed to be an eight
game match so the match is over why did
he resign capablanca is just better here
if you capture on e5 d captures only
five now the queen is under attack you
have to move the Queen Queen c8 and now
Queen to b3 threatens checkmate so what
do you do you have to ruin your pawn
structure even further on the King said
if g6 Bishop captures black will slowly
but surely fall apart here and if you go
f5 it's not much better you can just
capture on poisson after real captures
on f6 you can go Queen g3 and it's just
just a much better position for white
the point is under attack here if you
move it you're gonna get Bishop to e5
and now that you force send the rook to
move let's say here let's say Queen g6
you are once again infiltrating and and
the game will be over very soon so
that's what happens basically if you
decide to capture the pawn after this
Bishop to be one move if you don't
capture the pawn there's not much else
you can play you can just play something
like queenie 8 move the Queen Bishop to
b6 but all in all you're just gonna be
playing a worse position against
capablanca and Costas was already down
four to zero in this match so he did not
feel like and continue in this game he
did not feel he could beat kappa blanka
here with the black pieces to somehow
level the score in the match so a very
interesting match this 1919 match
between capablanca and Borislav Kostich
and it's very interesting if you
remember I mean beating someone of
course it's caliber five to zero is not
not a small feat if you remember these
are the standings of the 1918 New York
tournament you can see that Capablanca
did finish a point and had of course
stitch but Costas finished two points
ahead of Frank James Marshall so that
speaks in itself of course Excalibur and
it's just amazing how how kappa blanka
was able to beat him five to zero but
it's not five to zero like okay I did
use a Sava gave its quote above the
board he won one time he mentioned the
hostage scene or a couple plays like a
god and my dear Boris it is impossible
to do anything if you've seen all the
games from the match you know that
that's not really true cost you did get
some chances but you know having chances
and taking advantage of them are two
very different things
so that's one thing I wanted to mention
and also of course in those days you had
to justify your result in the match so
here is a nice justification not a
justification but here is a Oh cost it's
you know the point of view at this match
from the American chess Bulletin may
June 1919 so let's just read that
hostage states that he left New York
without a genuine ambition for the match
feeling that the odds were all against
him when he needed every possible
advantage against an opponent of the
Cubans caliber but he had given his word
and could not go back on it the climate
had a most unfortunate effect upon him
so that it was impossible for him to
play chess in anywhere near his normal
form in vain did he struggle against it
for severe headaches came up came upon
him after arrival necessitating the
attendance of a doctor who gave him
injections to relieve his condition
somewhat plaintively he reversed that he
that he did him little good as and the
fee only served to augment his
nervousness hostage often mentioned that
well both of the the expenses of the
doctor and the accommodations were very
high in Hawara
so he says he founded the air in the
center of the city where he took up
residence very tiring after six days of
this sort of thing he decided to play
with Capablanca and then he says the
first game was a most difficult
proposition for him
and he sat at the board for six
consecutive hours striving mightily not
to jeopardize his position which was
finally adjourned it had completely
exhausted him and the next day after a
sleepless night he was fairly distracted
so much so that he forgot his right
under the conditions to take off two
days for rest worse than that he
intended to play the Spanish game
something we already mentioned and he
had written down three Bishop to b5 on
the score sheet when suddenly he
realized that he had played
that he had played his Bishop to c4
bringing about an Italian give an
opening he never plays he lost that game
and took two days off resuming play in
the third game in comparatively good
condition after the working after
working up a fine position a feeling of
numbness which he ascribed to the
treatments he was undergoing overtook
him he missed his chance at the 12th
turn and three moves later chose the
wrong spot for the retreat of his Bishop
which caused him upon end the game from
the non-caustic says he was completely
demoralized being unfit to play at all
and that the rest did not count he
regrets the possibility the possibly
unpleasant impression the match may have
left upon chess supporters in Havana but
hopes to make amends at Hastings where
he expects to play in August and indeed
Costas did play in Hastings in August
and so did capablanca and as we are not
going to be covering that tournament
during the Capablanca saga we may be
sometimes in the future I will cover it
and then I'm just gonna add it the video
still Capablanca saga but now like I
mentioned we are going straight into the
match with Emmanuel Lasker but just for
your you know pleasure here are the
standings
well not that but here are the standings
of the tournament in Hastings and the
one cross-stitch played in August so
Capablanca won that tournament as well
ten and a half out of 11 only one raw
and interestingly the only draw
capablanca had was against abolished of
course dish so all of the games prior to
the match would cost each ended in a
draw and this match couple longer played
against Kostich after their match in
Havana in 1919 also ended in a row so a
very impressive showing by both of them
but seems like capablanca is just in the
top form in the best form of his life
and the Capablanca himself mentioned
this that he he felt here that he was in
the best shape of his life
so naturally he is ready to face a world
champion Emanuel asked her this is where
we are taking our cup of Blanca saga so
like I like I said do check out if
you're interested Bobby Fischer's
analysis of this game first link in the
description below and also there will be
a second link in the
it's the video we already made some time
ago in February the negotiations between
kappa blanka and Lasker for for their
for the first time they were supposed to
play their World Championship match
which did not take place so just you
know the if you haven't seen it do check
it out you'll enjoy the World Chess
Championship match much more so two
links in the description below to check
him out I would like to thank crystal
Kiefer for Jeff as Jeff g4 celebrates
his 40th birthday so I wish you all the
best sir rich Piper diamond portraits
Elise Francis and Matthew Smith for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous video serie
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon
continuing the Capablanca saga we are
going into the Watchers championship
match against emmanuel ask her checking
up on your suggestions and of course
following what's happening in the world
of chess thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day